now it is time to go back to guns for
the final thought the debates over gun
control and the Second Amendment give
off like the freedom seed spewing boom
sticks they center around lots of loud
noise and hot air here's the argument
for the Second Amendment it protects the
freedom of people from tyranny there are
endless statistics demonstrating the
public hazards and benefits of gun
ownership a homeowner protects his
family a woman protects herself against
an assailant a trained gun owner
prevents a mass shooting or terrorist
attack by killing the criminal before he
can kill the innocent people around him
but the essential defense of the
individual right to keep and bear arms
that Americans have cherished since 1789
is that it puts the government's money
where its mouth is and offers a blunt
defense against those hypothetical but
perfectly plausible oppressors who would
pervert the meaning of laws and language
to enslave us without the right to keep
and bear arms the people are ultimately
powerless the Second Amendment is the
constitutional provision that protects
all of the others that's our whole show
today
come back tomorrow we get your mailbag
questions in we're gonna be answering
all of the life-changing questions I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show come back tomorrow we'll do it all
again
[Music]
[Music]